[Music]
much like shanks or blackbeard before
him
kizuru is an elaborate carefully
constructed puzzle box of a character
that no matter how closely you look at
always seems to be missing some
essential pieces to reveal its full
picture
this shouldn't come as a big surprise
since he only has received very limited
screen time in the story so far
thoughtfully planned character
development after all is one of the most
crucial parts in creating a vivid and
capturing storyline
and as we know what is most needed for
genuine and organic character
development
is especially one thing time
so one would think that having only
limited screen time for
such an enormous cast as one piece would
be a striking disadvantage
resulting in shallow characters with
little room for emotional involvement
and yet it's exactly characters like
kizuru
shanks or blackbeard that have rita's
most excited
so what is the secret behind this
apparent paradox
the answer to that is simple oda is a
master of
mystery he takes the apparent handicap
of certain characters in the story
and turns it into a strength he makes
use of
every single panel that this character
is shown in to fletch out a certain
image for his audience
however compared to characters with more
screen time
he doesn't give them slow organic growth
over time
but much rather he hands us little
pieces of information about that person
based on these pieces you can then
create a rough image of the character in
your mind
however these pieces can be turned and
rearranged in different ways
and thus allow for different
interpretations and perspectives
a great example for this are all the
small pieces we have gathered for
blackbeard many of them are so different
that you can puzzle together various
possible images for his character
in some scenes he seems to be goofy in
others he seems cruel
and in again others he seems straight
out scared
this impression of inconsistency is
complemented by his mysterious power to
consume multiple devil fruits as well as
by his ambition to become
pirate king it is really barely more
than a handful of clues about who
blackbeard truly is
and yet he might be the most heatedly
discussed character
in the entire series the same applies to
shanks about whom we also only hold tiny
bits and pieces
and of course one of the characters that
can't be left out of this list
is kizuru being the admiral that we know
by
far the least about with the exception
of ryokugyo of course
kizeru is a prime example of how oda
manages to create
amazing characters by only giving them a
basic set of traits
and leaving the rest ambiguous and
unclear
how fitting then that kizaru follows the
path of
unclear justice and even though there
only is so much that we know about his
personality
and role in this story oda has left us
enough pieces of the puzzle to allow us
to figure out
what it means so in this video we will
try to put together the purpose kizeru
has in the story of one piece
and to do so we will answer the most
crucial questions surrounding his
character
what is unclear justice before we can
look at his ideological concept of
morality and justice however
we first have to understand who kizuru
is
as a person
same as his fellow admirals barcelina
kizuru is based on a famous japanese
actor thus his conceptual design is
heavily based on a character played by
actor kuni tanaka
in his youth beside their strikingly
similar lineaments their
similarities include kizeru's outfit his
birthday
and even his real name borcelino
the epithet kizuru he acquired when
rising into the ranks of the admirals
same as with his colleagues this epithet
consists of
a color and an animal in kizaru's case
this is
ki for yellow and zaru for monkey
making him the yellow monkey accordingly
zakazuki
is akainu the red dog while kuzan is
aokiji the blue pheasant oda chose these
animals based on the famous folk tale of
momotaro who befriended a pheasant a dog
and a monkey to accompany him on his
journey
next to his very interesting visual and
contextual design
kizeru is without a doubt also one of
the most powerful characters in the
world of one piece
in fact based on his devil fruit it is
actually quite hard to determine
how strong he might actually be after
all being
light itself would easily make him the
fastest character in the story
additionally if oda were to be more or
less physically accurate with this fruit
it would most likely also make him the
most overpowered character
however we can assume that there are
certain limitations to that power
nonetheless we have never seen kizeru
really go all out before
so we don't really know what he might
truly be capable of
accordingly we also do not know a lot
about borsellino's past
there is a single image of him as a
child suggesting him to be rather kind
and smart while brooding over a pile of
books
we know that he joined the marines at a
young age around the same time as
sakazuki
and similar to his peer he quickly rose
through the ranks and reached the status
of a vice admiral
at a fairly young age the only thing
that we know about his time then
is that he was the one responsible for
capturing arlong
after fischer tiger's death small fun
fact regarding this panel here
the head that kizuru is wearing here is
actually called a
borsolino which is the name of italy's
oldest manufacturer of luxury hats
see we're learning stuff about the world
while talking about one piece
isn't that fun moving on the most
defining arc for
kizeru's character is undoubtedly saba
odi where he is
sent after luffy's attack on one of the
tenryubito
while he has no problem taking on the
entirety of the worst generation on his
own
he doesn't manage to catch even a single
one of them in the end
being hindered by raley's and kuma's
interceptionist pursuit
and despite being one of the strongest
forces present during the war at
marineford and
taking on the likes of whitebeard and
marco single-handedly
he doesn't play any major role in the
war's outcome
what really stands out about kizuru's
character therefore are
not his actions but much rather his
personality
and i'm not gonna lie it's one of my
favorites in the story so far
oda depicts kizuru as an going and laid
back person
in fact he is so laid back that at times
he
appears to be slow in his reactions and
almost slothful
which has resulted in a number of stoner
jokes surrounding his character
and you guys better put some good ones
in the comments
what makes kizuru a true favorite of
mine however is the fact that he's one
of the rare characters in the story
that has a genuinely sarcastic nature
he often talks about how scary or
shocking a situation is but
completely lacks the corresponding
facial expression
in my personal opinion characters with a
sarcastic take on things are
immensely entertaining however they are
quite hard to write and convey to a
general audience
which is why they are so rarely found
inside the shonen genre
as a result this trait gives kizuru an
air of cleverness and
sharpness in comparison to other
characters that take
everything at face value this impression
is complemented by his cool composure
no matter how intense the situation
might be he always appears to be in
control of his emotions
to the reader this conveys a strong
sense of confidence in his own abilities
we can see this in his absent-mindedness
during battle
not fearing any damage as well as in his
lack of awareness for
collateral damage despite his immense
battle strength but
maybe in connection to his laidback
personality kizaru seems to lack
personal ambition not only is he the
only one of the former three admirals
that didn't aspire to become fleet
admiral
he also seems to have no interest in
authority in general
he doesn't like giving orders but
prefers receiving them
and we can even see him taking
directions from santomaru
one of his own subordinates nonetheless
kizuru is deeply respected within the
ranks of the marines
his most defining trait however might be
his
fearlessness not only does borsolino
take on whitebeard and the entire worst
generation by himself
but he even offers to go to wano and
confront kaido
and big mom on his own something that
even akainu is reluctant to do
now as mentioned before all these puzzle
pieces give us a rough image of kizeru's
character
however we still like the full image for
instance we have no idea what kizuru
actually values or what his great desire
and drive is
we just can't see it yet it's all still
unclear what we do know however is that
kizuru
shares neither a kind of sense of
absolute justice and hate toward pirates
nor kusan's kind and forgiving nature
he much rather appears like an old
teacher that intervenes and lectures
when necessary
but stays out of everyone's business
otherwise we even see him specifically
targeting luffy during marineford to
lecture him about the gap between him
and those on the battlefield
so based on this insight we have
gathered until now
let's deconstruct what the concept of
unclear justice
actually means and what it tells us
about kizuru's role
in the story
based on his personality and the
construction of his character
i would argue that there are three
distinct interpretations of kizuru's
concept of
unclear justice the first one of these
is rather straightforward
kizeru's justice is unclear because he
often seems indecisive and without
directions in decisions and objectives
he makes
back on saba odi for instance he
immediately delays his mission to look
for santomaru
once santomaru contacts him he goes back
to looking for luffy before
once again getting sidetracked by the
other supernova
once he defeats them however he doesn't
bother to capture them but once again
leaves to find the straw hats
finally ending up not capturing anyone
but sacking 500 other pirates instead
it is quite possible that this stems
from his sense of invincibility which
makes you wonder how powerful kizuru
truly is if he's able to be this
unfocused in his actions his way of
decision making lacks a clear direction
and strife as a kainu and aokiji do
which
makes it unclear and speaking of his two
fellow admirals
this brings us to the second way of
looking at his justice
because it's especially unclear when put
between the two extremes that are a
kainu and aokiji
kizuru's justice is unclear because it
falls on neither side of the spectrum
he neither follows zakazuki's absolute
justice
that is built on hatred towards all
pirates and militaristic strictness
nor kuzan's lazy justice that is based
on morality and fairness
instead as the saba odi example shows
really well
borsellino's sense of justice seems to
be movable on the scale between red and
blue
trying to capture the straw hats failing
but then capturing 500 other pirates in
the process
shows us how his sense of justice sways
between thoroughness and fairness in
one go while it might be very easy to
agree with one of the extreme positions
kizaru might actually be the admiral
that is the most
objective out of the three being neither
unnecessarily cruel nor
unnecessarily forgiving kizeru can be
seen as the balanced middle between
akainu and kuzan
now obviously this doesn't take into
account how flawed and unjust the
political structure of the one piece
world truly is
which might arguably make kuzan's path
more justified
at least for me personally but based on
the assumption that the marines are
actually supposed to be a neutral
organization in the service of the
people
kizaru would bring the necessary
flexibility and objectivity in his
actions
the thing is that we don't know what
ideals kizeru follows and what his dream
for the world is
which already brings us to the last
meaning of unclear justice
oda deliberately keeps kizeru's true
nature unclear for us to see
we still miss a few decisive pieces of
the puzzle to
truly understand who kizuru is as a
person
so i'm fairly confident that kizuru will
still have to play a major role in the
future of the story
and once we will learn more about him we
might also get a better picture of him
maybe in the end his unclear justice
will turn
into clear justice after all